what is the type of this quadrilateral
be as specific as possible with the
given data
so it's clearly is a quadrilateral we
have four sides here
and we see that two that we have two
pairs of parallel sides or we could also
say there are two pairs of congruent
sides here as well
this side is parallel and congruent to
this side this side is parallel and
congruent to that side so we're dealing
with a parallelogram
let's do more of these
so here it looks like a same type of
scenario that we just saw in the last
one we have two pairs of parallel and
congruent sides but all the sides aren't
equal to each other if they're all equal
to each other we'd be dealing with a
rhombus but here they're not all equal
to each other this side is congruent to
the side opposite this side is congruent
to the side opposite that's another
parallelogram
now this is interesting we have two
pairs of sides that are parallel to each
other but now all of the sides have the
e have it equal length so this would be
a parallelogram and it is a
parallelogram but they're saying to be
as specific as possible with the given
data so saying it's a rhombus would be
more specific than saying it's a
parallelogram this does satisfy the
constraints for being a parallelogram
but saying it's a rhombus gives us tells
us even more not every parallelogram is
a rhombus but every rhombus is a
parallelogram here they have the sides
are parallel to the side opposite and
all the sides are equal let's do a few
more of these
what is the type of this quadrilateral
be as specific as possible with the
given data
so we have two pairs of sides that are
parallel and or we have i should say one
pair we have a pair of sides that are
parallel and then we have another we
have another pair of sides that are not
so this is a trapezoid but then they
have two choices here they have
trapezoid and isosceles trapezoid now an
isosceles trapezoid is a trapezoid where
the two non-parallel sides have the same
length just like an isosceles triangle
you have two sides have the same length
well we can see these two non-parallel
sides do not have the same length so
this is not an isosceles trapezoid if
they did have the same length then we
would pick that because that would be
more specific than just trapezoid but
this case right over here this is just a
trapezoid
let's do one more of these
what is the type of this quadrilateral
well we could say it's a parallelogram
because all of the sides are parallel
but if we wanted to be more specific you
could also see that all the sides are
the same so you could say it's a rhombus
but you could get even more specific
than that you notice that all of the
sides are intersecting at right angles
so this is if we wanted to be as
specific as possible this
is a square
let me check the answer
got it right